foreign
I hope you guys can hear me right now
before we start with today's stream
another quick announcement you guys are
down there I'm up here yes why because
my camera's not working
thank you for asking
regardless
today is the last day the last day of
what the last day for the drop for the
collection drop if you want to get this
fine nice sweater and the oversized tee
that goes on top of it that I didn't
wear today because I wanted to show the
the sweater by itself alhamdulillah then
hit the link in the description seventh
Earth Studios and get yours today now
let me bring up a friend of mine to tell
you the same thing
I was thinking of you when I set up this
camera position nice nice I'm like I
need I need to level up on him he has a
voice he has the beard I need the uh you
know the the height
but it's sorry because we both got the
brother got the hoodie exactly exactly
hey man
hey man that's clean
[Laughter]
all right Bismillah so
you guys are late yeah I know I'm late I
know like I mentioned my camera is
giving me some difficulties okay you can
always watch it back later if you want
to
let us should we just throw up the video
and start talking just throw it up bro
all right let me grab it
see this as a threat in Islam I I chose
a longer video so it's about 10 minutes
so that's that's cool all right
I see this as a threat in Islam in the
more fundamentalist forms of Islam it's
like well you should submit to Ella it's
like hey fair enough
Ella as interpreted by who oh uh
totalitarian misogynistic mullahs how
about no
I I don't buy your Ella and I don't see
who made you the right I can't remember
who said this but uh someone said that
the poor belief uh religion is true the
middle class believes it's false and the
rich believe it's useful or the powerful
believe it's useful uh I I'm not
powerful or Rich but I certainly
consider it useful and I can see that
the lack of it has its negative impact
as well I just don't wish to submit
myself to a rigid ideology of that kind
combined with the fact I don't believe
in the bigger the guy in the sky right
okay so let's not make it okay so let's
agree that you shouldn't subordinate
yourself arbitrarily to a rigid
structure now you might want to do that
sporadically to discipline yourself
right but the the object shouldn't be
submission
now that what's weird in the biblical
narrative you know is that the the goal
is not submission
so weird it's covenantal relationship
and covenantal relationship is actually
relationships so one of the things you
see with Moses for example and you also
see this with Abraham is that they're
constantly negotiating with God
that's why my the name of my next book
by the way is we who wrestle with God
it's a negotiation it's not a submission
and so God is always threatening to wipe
out the Israelites in the desert he's
just sick and tired of their idol
worship and their whiny resentment and
their bitterness and their worship of
the past tyranny and he's constantly
threatening just to wipe them out and
start again
okay
he has said so much already just just
from that one minute he has said and the
the host as well said so much and I want
to try and and kind of unpack it because
sometimes when he speaks it's hard to
understand what he's saying
um so I'm going to try my best on packet
Bismillah
so aside from the clip in the beginning
because it's going to come back they
just did like a little coming up the guy
started by by saying the poor believe in
God insinuating they have nothing else
to do the middle class they don't
because they for some reason think
they're they're too good they have what
they need or they're too focused on the
world maybe and the upper class think
it's useful so they could take advantage
of those below them you know the elites
they use religion to keep people
oppressed now this is a stupid silly
narrative it's a liberal not liberal
versus conservative but like libertarian
liberal
um narrative that's been created since
the Renaissance you know since Europe
was enlightened
and they came out of the Dark Ages
mainly because of Islam Again by the way
and uh they had this belief that listen
the church kept us under for so long we
want to be free so they made liberalism
to make people as free as possible and
that is when they had they created this
narrative that religion is just invented
to keep people under
their oppression
built up for so long into this energy
that just exploded into I want to be
free and all religion sucks and the
energy is being transferred down
generation to generation and that's why
we have this narrative around today ask
yourself why does this narrative exist
you don't know it just does I just told
you why so
they're going race off this narrative
and then the host himself big man in the
sky with a beard clearly talking about
Christianity again and by the way with
no disrespect to Christianity they kind
of ruin things for a lot of the other
major religions because a lot of
Christianity is one of the biggest
religions so when they mess up people
just lump all religions in under their
banner and say well look Christianity
believes in this and that how does God
love everyone even people who do
insanely horrible things
we don't have that stuff in Islam bonho
how are you feeling about the video so
far man
I'm just trying to understand like where
he's coming from like what happened
mentally with him that he had this like
just switch up
you know because like we saw him in the
videos that he was making with Muhammad
yeah and it seemed as though he was
actually listening he was sincere he was
making some kind of progress yeah uh but
what I don't understand is that he's
saying that
uh like you have the prophets like Moses
and Issa
and he's saying that they were they were
wrestling with God but they weren't
submitting
they definitely were submitting to God
like every single Prophet has submitted
to God every single person in this world
submits to God and if you're not
submitting to God then you're going to
submit to something else so what is that
other thing that you're submitting to is
it money
is it the government
like what is it you know that's the real
question so I'm just kind of confused
that he's saying they did not submit
like where is he getting this
understanding from
yeah yeah so he's he's going based off
the Bible
um and the Bible
it does have this narrative uh you know
we've read some verses that even talk
about some of the prophets of God you
know and what it says that they did so
it wouldn't be surprising
um I think for him specifically
I think it's it's never a black and
white thing right it's always complex
many different colors
um that go into this kind of thing so I
think there are personal reasons there
are you know reasons around this
upbringing I think there are uh maybe
even financial reasons I know he's
employed by a very specific organization
who I will not name that's backed by a
very specific group where I also will
not name
um but if you guys want to do their
research just type into Google you'll
figure it out inshallah and you know
accepting Islam or something would
yeah so for many reasons but yeah what
are we gonna say well I mean he says in
the beginning too like oh you have to
submit to Allah and he's okay fair
enough but then he said uh uh you but
whose interpretation of Allah we're
talking about are they brought you
serious
like Allah the Creator the one who
created everything and everyone like how
is that so complicated why are you
complicating things yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I think I think when it it's weird
because this is something that's pointed
out in a discussion he had with Muhammad
hijab where as soon as he was asked
about a religious Endeavor he over
complicated the whole thing he literally
asked like Muhammad a job asked do you
believe in God or something like that
and Jordan Peterson responded by saying
what do you mean by do what do you mean
by you what do you mean by believe and
what do you mean by God excuse me
what I mean by do
I remember this yeah yeah it's it's it's
it's insane it's it's okay maybe we have
to define God no problem we'll Define
Godless it's not an issue because people
understand got to be different things
okay we'll Define God believe okay maybe
we can Define belief because Iman in
Islam right uh like faith is not just a
blind faith it's something based on
evidence so you can you can go based on
that as well you know you have evidence
to a reasonable degree
um to establish a belief that you have
uh in uh in a something or something or
someone something or someone pardon me
okay no problem but do and you come on
man
that's that's way too far but I also do
want to unpack the whole
thing he was talking about with you know
he doesn't want to submit to a kind of
he says this later it's totalitarian
regime or a rigid system why not
let's say you had the perfect system in
life you knew exactly how to live life
the best way to live life not just for
you but for all the society
that system will be rigid
because they will be specific
because they lived life in the best way
you have to be specific and I know you
know this because you talk about doing
your bed and cleaning your room when you
wake up in the morning that's that's
rigid and that's why that's why he gives
room you need to be rigid some places
you need to be rigid sometimes okay but
if you knew the perfect way to live you
would be rigid in all of it and that is
exactly what religion is pardon me
that's exactly what Sam is you are rigid
in where you need to be rigid you are
rigid in the best way of life now
God has given us you know leeway you
don't have to drink orange juice over
milk because one is a little bit better
than the other maybe you you know you
need calcium
over vitamin C or whatever like you know
that there is that that room for
interpretation that room for necessity
room for improvement a room for a leeway
right but
his issue is he doesn't understand Islam
he doesn't understand God and that's
something I'm going to dig into a little
bit later inshallah I'll save it but his
main issue the whole wrestling with God
why do you want to wrestle with God
and I'm so long I'm going to talk about
that later on but I'll let you inshallah
jump in before we continue no I think we
should definitely jump in because the
this is reminding me so much of like
different surahs or not different but
different Aya in Surah al-baqarah and I
want to bring them up but I also want to
continue so let's continue inshallah and
before we continue just a question to
the viewers right now like what are
y'all's thoughts what are y'all think
about what's going on so far what do you
think happened with Jordan Peterson with
the switch up as of recently do you
think this was Rami is uh do you think
it is what Rami is mentioning or do you
think it's something different do you
think that he was like this from the rip
it's a good question and let's leave
insults out of it no like oh he's crazy
or anything like that yeah only legit
answers inshallah
all right let's get back to the video
and that's the apocalypse I suppose and
Moses is constantly interceding on their
behalf and telling God he shouldn't
break his word and the odd thing in the
story is that God actually listens which
is rather Preposterous but but the
reason that's happening is to mitigate
against exactly the problem that you
described which is to have the
relationship with the Transcendent
degenerate into nothing but a blind
obedience and then the danger of that is
well a blind obedience
to who and I see this as a threat in
Islam in the more fundamentalist forms
of Islam it's like well you should
submit to Allah it's like hey fair
enough
Ella as interpreted by who oh uh
totalitarian misogynistic mullahs how
about no
I I don't buy your Ella and okay
okay I know I'm I'm pausing it again
fairly quickly but he's just throwing
like freaking Haymaker after a Haymaker
and you need to respond or else you're
gonna get hit bad so I have a question
for Jordan Peterson
he said he doesn't want to submit
totally to something okay
why do you submit fully to the Bible
being the historical Authority
why do you believe the Bible is a
historical Authority and with the
children of Israel why do you believe
that's actually how it went down why are
you even reading the Bible
why don't you believe it's a piece of
fiction
as opposed to a historical Authority why
strikes yeah it shows his inclination
towards Christianity to begin with so
there's a presupposition I already
believe the Bible is correct I already
see myself like the child of Israel the
children of Israel who's wrestling with
God why
why do you come to that conclusion when
there has been intellectual discourse
had with you
yeah
it makes sense one
it really does make sense and and
I had to say this but it it's kind of
sad to see such an intellectual
individual
come down to this point
where he's he's speaking in a way where
it's almost like he's trying to
run in circles you know he's trying to
confuse the uh the person who's
listening
well maybe he's trying to confuse
himself bro because a lot Knows Best
a lot of items but you know what I have
before you continue I have an Ayah bro
this it just hit me perfectly
I took a picture because I want to
recall it a hundred percent
but it's in uh Suraj so the second
chapter in the Quran and the 28th verse
Allah says how can you deny Allah
you were lifeless and he gave you life
and he will cause you to die and again
bring you to life and then to him you
all will be returned
and it's like bro I just want to bring
this question up
Jordan Peterson at one point
he was talking about that he had this uh
crippling autoimmune disorder
and that he had to like he had so much
depression and his energy was Zapped and
he just felt terrible
and the moment he started eating
Carnival
right that his these things started
going away he started actually feeling
good again he's the person that he had
and there's anxiety all the stuff that
just started going away he started
feeling good again
it's like do you not realize that was a
blessing that was a gift
you know like Allah can easily take this
away from you so why why would you why
would you say that you're not going to
submit submit to the one who who is
giving you this gift submit to the one
who's giving you this eyesight this
ability to hear this ability to have
this this logic and intellect that you
you saw huh
so say how can you not submit to the one
who created you in disregard
that's a very beautiful Point bro
watercolor figum that's a very beautiful
point
a man like him especially nowadays you
know he's uh I would say he's very
blessed in a lot of ways I'm sure he has
this test in the tribulations 100 he's
also been very blessed in a lot of ways
there's a video where he was talking
about how much money he makes
obviously money's not everything but um
there are people who are you know on the
brink of death because they don't have
money so or they live a very long
difficult life because they don't have
money you know it's something that God
has blessed him with given him so you
bring up a very very good point you know
why are we not taking these things into
consideration Allah says
he says and proclaim the blessings of
your lord or ask for the blessings of
your lord Proclaim them you know he's
sitting here I want to wrestle with God
excuse me
you don't you don't you don't even
control your own heart beating and you
want to wrestle with God come on man now
he's gonna say that we're strawmenting
his points and all that stuff someone
made an interesting point he doesn't
actually believe that about the Bible
why is he speaking about it in that way
then now he's gonna say I'm just making
a general Point whether it's true or not
that's the story that's given there and
okay no problem I do I want to discuss
this trying to run around the circle
yeah let him let him run around I mean
we're all gonna run around till we die
it's a matter of who's on the truth at
the end and that's why we want to have
this discussion inshallah and we do it
because we genuinely care about people
you know we're not we're not trying to
make a hit piece against Jordan Peterson
the only thing
I want from him is to accept the truth I
would love for him to accept the truth
that's it and just just like Muhammad
invited him to Islam we invite him to
Islam the whole Muslim invites you to
Islam we want you as our brother but
first you have to put your ego down and
you have to really ask God to Guardian
you have to reflect on it inshaallah now
there's a point I want to make
and that point is
and I I think this is something that I I
have to be firm on because I only see
two options when you are talking about
wrestling with God and describing the
way the children of Israel did in the
Bible correcting God or telling God to
hold his word which who the heck do they
think they are to say that by the way
unless they don't understand who God is
especially as the Jews they're very
strict with their understanding of God
you know not associating Partners all
that stuff so it's very surprising that
you know there's this this narrative in
the Bible apparently but when you talk
about
wrestling with God you are either trying
to make yourself into a God or a Godlike
figure so you can wrestle up there with
him or you're trying to humanize God and
I think you're doing a little bit of
both to make it more even I think you're
giving yourself way too much credit
you don't know as much as you think you
do I know you're older and you have a
lot of wisdom you know psychology you're
not as you don't know as much as you you
think you do you know there are a lot of
things that for example I know cookies
exist right I know there's there's a
recipe for cookies I know I don't know
that recipe
so I know that I don't know it how many
imagine I didn't know cookies existed
imagine all the foods I don't know exist
and I don't know the recipe imagine all
the things you don't even know that you
don't know you're just completely
unaware of their existence so you don't
know anything about them or their their
surrounding facts or anything I know
it's a big the big concept there so
forgive me for going so deep
but I know Jordan Peterson will
understand that inshallah and I hope
that I didn't make it too complicated so
there's all the stuff you don't even
know and you're putting yourself up here
I want to wrestle with God I don't want
to have a rigid structure who are you
I'm sorry I'm sorry in a light of An
Almighty all-powerful all-knowing
Creator who are you and one more thing
so I know I'm going on a lot forgive me
for it but if I were to go to Dr Jordan
Peterson and I I would ask am I your
equal in the field of psychology
of course you would say no I would I
would hope that he says no if he says if
he doesn't then I think you know that's
a little disrespectful to himself in his
own field so he would probably say no
I'm not you're equal I'm higher than you
and if I ask wise because his his
experience his knowledge his wisdom his
his degree all these things his
qualifiers he has things that qualify
him and that I don't have
okay in light of God all-knowing all
wise all powerful all capable created
everything including you who are you
compared to God are you as equal no not
even close so why are you talking about
having a red destruction not having a
registructure what's up no the wrestling
as well how can you wrestle with
something like this
exactly exactly you know the last time
and by the way it's so funny he talked
about how God threatened to destroy the
children of Israel and by the way in the
Quran he mentions how he did and then he
brought them back and he did and he
brought them back he turned some of them
to Apes he did you know as punishments
for them God literally split open a sea
for them
split open the sea and they walked
through it and then God used that same
sea to destroy their enemies and they
still disobeyed him of course God is
going to threaten to destroy them of
course God is going to destroy you're
talking about you're praising it
yeah I don't think being destroyed by
God is a good thing or being threatened
by to be destroyed by God is a good
thing I would rather be praised by God
for being a good servant I don't know
about you but no this is the necessary
relationship between the necessary
existence and everything that that he
created there's no other
um you know existence or a relationship
that could exist
um the prophets again they did not
wrestle with the engine needs to check
his sources because it's more so they
were asking
God they were begging God they were
making Dua they were praying and begging
God oh like
don't don't destroy our people you know
don't punish us they were they were
asking for forgiveness they were
repentant
so it's like again he needs to check his
Twisted well I really just want to
understand where is he coming from where
is he right now
yeah yeah 100 and it's a shame I feel
like there are so many ayats in the
Quran that I could quote that are just
not coming to my head I think one is
along the lines of you know who could
stop Allah from destroying all of
humanity and replacing them with another
creation who could stop Allah who could
stop Allah from uh from destroying him
and and you know replacing him with
somebody else
who would accept Islam
who's going to protect you on the day of
judgment
you know who's gonna who's gonna
intercede for you now that I think about
it there's only one
individual that actually tried to
wrestle with Allah and that didn't end
up very well for him did it talk about
Bliss yeah yeah yeah
so what happened with Elise
well
first he didn't want to submit look at
that
subhanallah he's saying that oh no it's
not about submission it's not about it's
not about submission clearly it's about
submission yes the relationship aspect
is very important but that comes from
the submission aspect as well
you know and and at least when he was
ordered to prostrate to Adam the
creation that he just made
he didn't do it
right he he rejected that he did not
submit and what happened when he did not
submit
please mommies
Allah said his disgrace and he it was an
outcast so he outcasted him from heaven
bro
distant destined for the Hellfire
now understanding this
would you would you take this logic
would you still run with this logic and
say no uh it's actually wrestling with
the with Allah not having a relationship
I wouldn't run with that logic
100 100
and he could probably take that same
narrative with this with the the Lucifer
in the Bible or whatever you know the
Fallen Angel we don't believe Satan was
a fallen angel
um but you know he could probably take
that same narrative you know what made
him an outcast
I don't know
so I think it's very very very clear now
that the only relationship that you can
have with your creator is a subservient
one
there is no other kind of relationship
you can have unless he and exalted is
Allah decides that you'll have some
other kind of relationship but
on the basis on a basic level
there's no other relationship you can
really have except uh one of
subservients that you submit to him
fully because of who he is you know we
have this topic in Islam of why God is
worthy of worship that's actually an
important thing to discuss why is God
worthy of our worship which is us you
know exalting uh saying his praise
um in obeying him as well you know
praying to him and all that stuff and
doing acts of worship for him and
obeying him as well why it's because of
who God is
you know why do people you know praise
famous athletes or whatever it's it's
because of who they are what they can do
what they're capable of and all that
stuff you know Michael Jordan's not just
the best because he he is you know it's
because of very specific church that he
has that makes him the best he
outperformed everyone God outperforms
everything because he created everything
and he's better than everything and
everyone in existence it's not a hard
concept to understand therefore you can
only fully submit to him and if you
don't submit to him you'll submit to
something else and it's very clear
Jordan Peterson that you are a man who
is currently submitting to his own
desires and his own whims and I think
that's a very sad state to be in for a
man especially someone who a lot of
young men look up to
yeah I still don't think he's submitting
to himself yeah I mean Allah knows best
but I think he's committing to like an
organization or
uh
oh I don't know I'm not going to say you
you know exactly what I'm talking about
yeah yeah yeah and the viewers if you
don't know
I think you do I think you do yeah yeah
it's very possible Long Island and um
yeah it could be multiple things as well
Knows Best
I don't see who made you the
size and even if I
Sky I'm not sure I need a middleman to
talk to him
right well that makes you a good
Protestant well but look we could well
we could also go down that rabbit hole a
little bit
it's worth it because I also think this
is how we ended up in this post-modern
um excess liberal conundrum so Jung
talked about Catholicism as we mentioned
and he talked about the utility of the
and mercy of the confessional and that
possibility of atonement but he also
laid out you know the dangers of that
the dangers of the Catholic structure is
uh what would you say a tilt towards
authoritarian rigidity which is what the
Protestants rebelled against
but then the question is well what's the
danger of the Protestant Revolution and
the danger is that everybody becomes his
own church
and then here's the problem you tell me
what you think about this here's the
logical conclusion of that you're your
own church you're your own God now you
can say what God said to Moses out of
the depths of the burning bush you can
say I am what I am
and I would say that's what the identity
politics types do
they say look I am so superordinate in
my own self-defining identity that no
matter what identity claim I put forward
it is incumbent upon you to accept it as
if it comes from an omniscient source
and I think like I as far as I can tell
Constantine that's where we are right
increasingly by force of law if you make
an identity claim no matter how
Preposterous which implies that there's
some limit to Identity claims by the way
like I have to accept
well there's one example in in
Ontario right now this become famous for
its surreality so there's a female
teacher in a suburb in Toronto who has
decided at the rape old age of something
approximating 50 that he's actually a
woman but he's not just a woman man he's
he's the Earth goddess herself and he
wears these like 144 quadruple D
prosthetic breasts I don't know if
you've seen pictures yeah
okay
now he's talking about the issues with
with being too liberal so what I see
here is is a confused human being and I
don't blame him many every every human
being is lost right
indeed mankind is in loss
except those who believe
and those who do good deeds
and those who exalt each other towards
patience and sorry those who exalt each
other towards truth
and those who exhaust each other towards
patients so I see a lost a lost
individual who
you know he's struggling between having
a you know a religious rigid way of life
where he you know lives according to
what God wants and not being undermined
by a totalitarian regime and all this
stuff and
I want to make it very simple
you should never and actually I think
Islam is the exact solution for what he
is fighting against with his one Hadith
right so obviously we should submit to
Allah we've established that
now he's worried about
you know uh totalitarian misogynistic
mullahs or whatever
which by the way shows his understanding
of our imams in Islam it shows his
understanding of and those who we take
the you know knowledge of the Quran and
the Deen from they're all what
totalitarian misogynistic mullahs excuse
me
you're going to praise these people who
wrestle with God and you're going to
completely undermine 1400 years of
scholarship to these you know these
these two degenerate terms come on and
I'm going to talk more about that
inshallah in a bit
but
I want to be careful about how I say it
let me just say that he said there is no
obedience to people with disobedience to
Allah so if anyone were to say something
that goes against Islam
you don't obey that person
and there have been instances in Islamic
history where the person was completely
so far off
the Muslims rebelled against that person
he did so much you know bad that it
basically took him out of the fall of
Islam and they rebelled against that
person this is early Islamic history by
the way
so
you know we don't have that totalitarian
authoritarian rigid structure you obey a
human being
there have been bad leaders yes for
every nation including Muslims there
have been bad leaders
but that doesn't make God
any less God that doesn't make the
religion any less true it just makes the
people bad you can say this about
anything liberalism
uh socialism Christianity Judaism Islam
anything because of the People Are
People we have free will now let me talk
about one case in which the the leader
was a little more authoritarian
we called them the the mutasila
um they're they're one this one leader
at some point
he got caught up with an argument it was
like a logical semantical argument you
know it was
is the Quran the word of God yes is
Jesus the word of God yes
okay is Jesus created yes is the Quran
created
uh
I guess it is
that's a semantic point he fell into and
we all we all know that whoever says the
Quran is created there are many you know
they say that person actually falls out
of the fold of Islam
because they have lied against Allah in
the Quran so
he fell into this and this leader he is
going to everyone he put himself over
everyone he's like everyone needs to say
the Quran is created
and the show who you know you know gave
in they gave in there are some children
who tried to get around from it you know
they would say the Quran the Bible the
Torah they would go wiggle the fingers
and say these three were made by Allah
so when they say these three they're
talking about their fingers right
um they tried to get out of it but there
was one Imam
Imam Ahmed
humble he fought against it and he was
beaten for it these are our imems these
are Honorable Men better than you and me
they fought for the truth they fought
for the truth of Islam
against these you know these these
totalitarian regimes whatever you want
to call them that's what Islam is and
that is the you know the the religion
that we are supposed to follow but you
want to borrow our imams down you know
our Pious and righteous imams down to
totalitarian misogynistic models excuse
me and by the way
there's etiquettes
there are etiquettes in Islam all you
have to do is ask for their evidence
if they cannot provide evidence
I guess I was talking too much for Angel
he dipped if they cannot provide
evidence
for what they're saying
from the Quran in the life of the
Prophet peace upon him
then you don't take it from them it's
very simple so to bring it all full
circle Dr Jordan Peterson
the main problem you have is the problem
with every that everyone struggles from
every single person has this issue
they cannot balance
submission to God
with uh this liberal lifestyle that they
feel they need to live
and the the problem in the middle is who
do you take the religion from
the problem in the middle is who do you
take the religion from and Islam solves
this issue like I mentioned to bring It
full circle
there is no obedience to people with
disobedience to God meaning if somebody
who is supposed to be an authority over
you tells you something that goes
against what God wants or describes as a
good way of living you do not listen to
them
islamically yes in Islam including in
Imam including a scholar including a
ruler including you know whoever it is
your boss your employer your parents
your husband whatever you don't have to
listen to that and that's the beauty of
Islam that is the beauty of Islam and I
think you would be I know you would be
much much happier of a man if you were
to accept Islam like many many people
have very recently
I know I went off for a while I'm sorry
but I'm done
okay
zoom out to the video is it
um there's more but I think he shifts
away from Islam and religion and goes
more to like liberalism and all that
stuff so we can watch if the people want
but I don't think it's necessary I think
we should stick to this
yeah let's just stick to this bro
all right so um let's let's bring the uh
the comments up inshallah I think this
is a very important comment that needs
to be addressed
um Romney doesn't know how to bake
cookies
I'm gonna be honest I have baked cookies
before actually
and I followed a recipe so I don't have
it memorized but they were really good
cookies
um
why you gotta need why do you need to
know how to bake cookies when you know
how to make s'mores
that is a good question which by the way
s'mores thank you Angel because he
taught me how to make uh s'mores are so
much better than cookies in my opinion
they were good it's beautiful we were
combining different chocolates and all
this oh my God man it was amazing second
question where is fayad he is chilling
right now may Allah bless them everyone
make Dua for him that Allah blesses him
and increases him inshallah he will be
back for the next time you just couldn't
make it today
so
what do you think of this he knows the
truth but his ego and pride stop him
from accepting the truth yeah like I
said I think it's both this and the fact
that he's being
this like some
I don't know some group of people or
someone else that's like controlling him
from behind the scenes
you know like like he he did mention
that he's making a lot of money with all
these different things that he's doing
so who's to say that
the sources where he's making his money
like the the way that he's getting the
money for these different things is not
connected to these things
and whereas if he were to say something
or if you were to let's say stop
believing in Islam or something like
this where he essentially starts cutting
off all these sources of income
yeah you're absolutely right
and um my camera turned back on God has
blessed me again with good quality
but
absolutely right you know that's that
whether people like to admit it or not
on a fundamental level and as a
psychologist he should know this that or
will always impact a person because they
make their decision emotionally before
they logically think about it and it's
only natural and it's you know even for
people like him
yeah and if you play back you will
actually see that he was very
emotionally charged in his responses
yeah and granted I mean if you play back
this string you will see that we were
actually very emotionally charged as
well in our responses but it's it's
because it's
I feel like it's something so simple
that he's just complicating so much and
trying like I said he's trying to run
around in circles he's trying to run
away from the point he's trying to beat
around the bush
yeah absolutely 100 and um I think I
think this has been a long time coming I
think this goes back to the discussions
he's had with Muhammad I think maybe he
didn't expect Islam to be as
um truthful as it was as clear as it was
as evidential as it was I think he did
assume it's just like any other religion
and because of that he's like I can I
can kind of Wiggle away from I can get
away from it um he's probably I think
he's struggling with that so he asked or
maybe he just generally misunderstands I
think the fact and the biggest problem
is is the fact that he still thinks or
believes that Islam is just this
complete totalitarian like you know
North Korea type uh you know
authoritarian regime and uh that are you
know uh imams or mullahs or whatever are
misogynistic and totalitarian which is
very sad because as a as an individual
he's been called misogynistic many many
times before
so it's so sad to see him erect the
straw man and throw this label onto what
every single uh Imam in Islamic history
I think it's it's very very sad but
inshallah
you know I hope that he'll come around
and um maybe maybe we should make some
Drive what do you think yeah we should
but before we make the Dua why don't you
replay the very beginning part of the
video so that way the viewers can see
that he was emotionally charged in his
response and when someone's emotionally
charged like this
uh well it lets you know there's
definitely some kind of bias he's
leaning towards One Direction or there's
just something else going on here like
it's not coming from a grounded place if
he were to have said all this in a
grounded place
I think we will be viewing this slightly
different now would we be refuting it of
course we will be refuting it because I
mean it still doesn't make sense
logically speaking and any True Believer
any mean anyone in the right State of
Mind will say the same thing but it's
just the fact that he was emotionally
charged it lets us know that again
something's happening like where is he
what's going on because it's something
clearly doesn't make sense here
absolutely 100 so let me play it and
then shallow everyone can see what
Anna's referring to here
I see this as a threat in Islam in the
more fundamentalist forms of Islam it's
like well you should submit to Allah
it's like hey fair enough
Ella as interpreted by who oh uh
totalitarian misogynistic mullahs how
about no
I I don't buy your Ella
keep it going keep it going well the guy
starts saying you know the things about
the uh the men in the sky or something
like this and then he's like he's
supposed to get like hyped up he's
supposed to get like really into it and
like starts to get out of his chair and
everything
let's see who made you the ghost
but someone said that the poor belief
religion is true the middle class
believes it's false and the rich believe
it's useful or the powerful believe it's
useful uh I I'm not powerful or Rich but
I certainly consider it useful and I can
see that the lack of it has its negative
impact as well I just don't wish to
submit myself to a rigid ideology of
that kind combined with the fact I don't
believe in the bigger the guy in the sky
right okay so let's not make it okay so
let's agree that you shouldn't
subordinate yourself arbitrarily to a
rigid structure
but you see what I'm saying you see like
there was definitely a response a
reaction I should say yeah
yeah 100 definitely definitely triggers
something uh within him
but um
playing it back actually made me think
of
a point
and I think it was a really important
point but I don't remember what it was
now
oh yeah yeah a lot is interpreted by who
I think I spoke with those about this
before but I don't feel like I made the
point clear enough
Allah interpreted by who
so Allah he describes himself in the
Quran
and there's only so many ways to
interpret
you know a description of Allah for
example the all-knowing the all-wise
how you're going to debate with me on
what all knowing is or what all wise is
even if we were to debate on the like on
the basics of what it means to know
everything how much knowledge there is
is it infinite is it like all this all
these silly things
um at the end of the day God knows more
than anything or anyone else that exists
everything that there is no God knows it
and we are not like that okay moving on
all wise what is wisdom wisdom is
putting things in the rightful place at
the right time that's what wisdom is
okay God can do that 100 of the time we
can
all powerful okay same thing so you see
we're going down this track a lot as
interpreted by who it's very clear at
all in the processary describes him in
the Hadith
and it's very beautiful you know it says
Allah is as his servant sees him
so if you see him as a merciful and
forgiving he will be merciful and
forgiving
and you if you just expect God to punish
you okay then all God is going to you
know punish you because that's what you
expect from him there are many many
Hadith in in the son of the process and
I would love for Jordan Peterson to
explore this side of Islam because we
actually have such a beautiful
relationship with Allah what does Allah
say in the Quran
he says
he says those who believe and whose
hearts are content with the remembrance
of Allah indeed with the remembrance of
Allah the hard to find contentment and
this is something that Muslims who
believe in Allah you know they will all
respond to this is something that they
will all admit to because when you have
a relationship with your creator
you you are put you're put in a place in
life where you are you're almost
spiritually enlightened
not aware of you not everything but in a
way where you are connected with God we
have a very beautiful relationship with
Allah you know imagine
it says tell my servants
who have harmed themselves by committing
sins don't despair in the mercy of Allah
indeed God forgives all sins and it is
him who was the most forgiving most
merciful you want to wrestle with God
God wants to forgive you
God wants to if you walk one step Allah
it'll take what what is the Hadith the
hundred or a thousand if you run if you
walk towards Allah Allah will run you if
you go to Allah he'll come to you in
arms man this is your Lord this is the
one who created you Habibi this is the
one who created you and you want to
wrestle with him
Allah
and let me just correct it because you
said that Allah is how the servant sees
him
but listen if you see Allah someone that
you can wrestle with that that's not
what Allah is it's not what Allah is
going to be you know yeah yeah
that's where interpretation comes in
that's where you need the molas or the
imams to specify because you don't just
take one thing out of context and run
with the narrative you need all the
evidence in the Quran so you know I
think that's a good example to kind of
exaggerate the point of why we need the
those of knowledge and Allah says no
Quran you know when you don't know ask
those of knowledge ask the scholars and
just like in something in Psychology
when we don't know we go to people like
Dr Jordan Peterson who do know that yeah
yeah exactly you always go to the person
that knows better if you're going to the
gym you don't know how to work out you
go to someone who knows better whether
they're on YouTube whether it's the
trainer at the gym whether it's your
friend that knows better but you're
going to someone who knows better why
because instead of you wondering around
in the dark you are going to the person
who has already leveled up they're
already on level 10 you're on level one
so now they bring you up to level 10.
yeah yeah absolutely and that's the
story of life you know
you don't know you learn you work to be
better
and that's what Islam is Islam is the
Deen I'm sure he's heard this at the
very least it's a full way of life that
encompasses everything
so it tells you how to live life and how
to live life in the best way in a way
that pleases God as well
so
I mean it's actually very
straightforward and I would love for Dr
Jordan Peterson to to venture off and to
actually learn Islam and not just look
at it from a historical perspective
um and look at oh there is this battle
in this fight and then this happened to
happen look at our religion look at our
spirituality look at what we believe
about God look at our religion in a more
spiritual manner not just a more okay
this happened and that happened kind of
way
um I I promise you if you generally look
into it you will fall in love with it
yeah 100
so again this is not us
bashing the guys us uh just refuting
some points and then inviting him back
to Islam because clearly there's
something going on
so let's make Dua in here right now and
then let's open the floor up for the
viewers to share their thoughts
and all this good stuff inshallah
inshallah and also in the future
inshallah we will Implement a Colin
system so you guys can actually hop on
the stream and call in insha Allah being
said you're right that's McDonald's
first and foremost accept our fasting
and allow us to observe let us the night
of decree and accept from us our Good
Deeds on that day and every day before
and every day after Allah I mean may
Allah forgive us for our slips and our
mishaps and our mistakes because he is
the most forgiving and the most merciful
and as Allah says
indeed Allah forgives all sins and it is
him who was the most forgiving most
merciful anything that we have said
um that was incorrect is from ourselves
in shaytan we ask God to forgive us in
anything that we have said is good that
is good is from Allah we ask him to
reward us for it we ask Allah to guide
Dr Jordan Peterson to Islam to open up
his heart an alarm to see that Islam is
the truth and allow him to submit to
Allah with a full submission and a clean
heart Allah I mean we ask Allah
to allow us to be righteous leaders for
the ummah and leaders for the righteous
Allah I mean we ask Allah to accept our
Islam from us and grant us the highest
levels of Jannah and protect us from the
punishment of this life the punishment
of the grave and the punishment of the
hereafter
foreign
makes a very good point he says
Paradise is for the sincere
intellect alone will not get you in this
is man and you have to you really have
to think who gave you the intellect
Allah gave you the intellect so that you
could use it for a reason now what is
that reason for is so that you could
literally
you you can reflect on the blessings of
Allah reflect on the creation of Allah
reflect on Allah himself
is not so you can
refute Allah it's not so you can wrestle
with Allah
yeah yeah 100 percent
100 percent
and I think um
it's a good place to end
maybe uh
maybe we should recite just a little bit
of Quran something that is a good
reminder for us
before we end the stream what do you
think
inshallah no one else has anything to
say then by all means okay let's uh let
me see the comments a little bit
um our brother here says I never could
really understand how the Quran is
eternal I'm not saying it is not but I
never understood when the Quran is
eternal does not have one of the
attributes of God can someone explain so
the Quran
the Quran always existed with Allah
because Allah always had it you know in
his knowledge what is the Quran
it's a book and a book does not have to
be physical so that's why you can say
the Quran is is created because you know
the Quran has aspects of wisdom and so
on and so forth you could say it was
only given to mankind at a specific
point okay no worries but Allah always
had it so that's how it was eternal it
doesn't have an attribute of God because
it's not it's not a being right it's not
a being it only exists because Allah
um uh you know exists basically yeah and
you're gonna think it's it's a
revelation
right and the Revelation has to be
reviewed if somebody has revealed it
means it would it already existed before
and now it's being reviewed
that's a very variable Point 100 100
AJ Zach says the problem with people
that hate or are confused by religion
are the ones that think that Judaism are
the standard that's why he's mentioning
wrestling with God like uh like like the
Old Testament says
yeah 100 and a lot of people even the
host you know I feel bad we haven't
discussed him a lot uh he seems like he
believes in God but he just doesn't
believe in the bearded man in the sky
narrative that you know kind of is
thrown on the Christians which I don't
frankly I don't think Christians believe
that either but you know that's kind of
the narrative that has been thrown onto
them
um obviously you know they worship Jesus
and that's why
um they talk about this worship man
worship which we wouldn't really
disagree with to be honest the calling
that we we do think it's paganism
worshiping a man and so do uh the Jews
but I would like for him inshallah to
also look a little more into Islam and
and see what we believe because he seems
like he believes in God just not a very
specific version of it but he probably
believes in someone who's all-powerful
who's all-knowing you know a higher
power as they say and Islam is a no
disagreement with that so I think that
he would benefit greatly from Islam as
well because he says himself by the way
that
um he sees that there's benefit in
religion
alhamdulillah
and uh he says ah thank you brother Army
I finally understood the answers he
usually got
um way too intellectual for me haha no
worries may Allah bless you I'm glad you
asked just general good practice it's
it's better to ask
um an Imam or Sheikh because you know
we're very limited in our knowledge so
um but that one some that I didn't know
the answer
all right bro let's close out
all right previous citation inshallah I
just want to make sure I have the the
translation ready
um
give me one second
let me just pull it up in case
one of the things I hate the most is
when I
uh mispronounce the word of the Quran or
mistranslate it
verse 30.
here we go
okay
regime
Bismillah
[Music]
foreign
indeed you will die
and indeed they will die too
saying to the to the process
that he will die in the non-muslims day
everyone else will die but this is
something that could be attributed to us
as well you know we will die and
everyone around us will die as well then
on the day of judgment we're going to
settle all their disputes there's all
this talk about you know he was wrong
here he was wrong there and no I was
right and there's religion is right this
religion is wrong all the all of it's
going to be disputed on the day of
judgment Allah asks a very powerful
question
he says who then does more wrong than
those who lie about Allah and reject the
truth after it was it has reached them
and then he asked is hell not befitting
of a home for the disbelievers
and then he says and the one who was
brought the truth and those who embrace
it it is they who are the Righteous ones
it's like the subscriber cinnamon
intellect alone is not going to save you
yeah
100 percent
age
forgive us in grant us goodness with
that being said inshallah we're going to
go ahead and end the stream off may
Allah bless you all for attendant make
sure you share it with those who you
think will benefit from it inshallah and
share it um as much as you can with Dr
Jordan Peterson inshallah hopefully it
can get his uh you know reach him insha
Allah and uh with that being said
we'll see you on the next one is